[Música]
el Rey Carlos III realiza en Alemania Su
primera visita al extranjero desde que
pasó a suceder a su madre la fallecida
de Isabel II quien se sentó en el trono
por siete décadas navegando la
diplomacia internacional y ejerciendo
una influencia silenciosa pero vital
para el Reino Unido Carlos tercero debe
mantener la monarquía como una
influencia legítima en Europa y que es
visible a nivel global pero también debe
gestionar escándalos como las
acusaciones de abuso contra su hermano
Andrew vinculado al pederasta Jeffrey
epstein o la separación de su hijo Harry
y Meghan markle de la familia real por
denuncias de discriminación de la pareja
analizamos con Gabriela Morales casas
quien es periodista especializada en
realeza y sociedad y directora de El
principado Muchas gracias a usted por
estar con nosotros y comienzo Gabriela
preguntándole qué tan influyente es hoy
la monarquía más famosa del mundo y que
la diferencia de casos como España o
Bélgica
qué tal Muy muy buenos días
Mucho gusto en saludarlas pues es
influyente creo que a nivel popular aquí
estamos viendo unas imágenes y justo
acabo de colgar con una colega mía
alemana que se encuentra en la cobertura
en el lima y ella me contaba lo
siguiente dice a ver la gente estaba muy
contenta de verlo gente mayor eh
solamente había lugar en en la plaza
Esto sí lo voy a tener que leer porque
mi alemán no es muy bueno
gutenbergs había lugar para mil
quinientas personas es decir no se veía
muy abarrotado porque las propias
autoridades berlinesas decidieron que no
era ideal que hubiera demasiada gente
sin embargo el rey y la reina Camila
Bueno pues llegaron muy temprano
saludaron a la gente y si hablamos de
términos monárquicos Pues solo el ocho
por ciento de la población alemana
querría de vuelta monarquía el resto no
pero es curioso es muy popular en este
país a la gente como en Estados Unidos
le sucede que no son monárquicos y que
han tenido una historia conflictiva con
el Reino Unido les llama la atención
Quizás El glamour pero me parece que
también este tema tradicionalista
histórico de cómo puede ser que exista
una monarquía a estas alturas Yo creo
que esa es la influencia que tiene la
casa real de Windsor sin duda alguna en
el aquí estamos viendo cómo lo reciben
en el parlamento que es la primera vez
que un monarca ajeno pues o que un
monarca para el caso de la historia de
Alemania se dirige al parlamento
entonces Claro que es influyente Claro
que lo es desde el momento en el que lo
recibe el presidente
desde el momento en el que el canciller
que a pesar de que tiene algunos
llamados en contra de la monarquía pues
lo recibió hoy esta mañana y que le
hayan dado el honor de hablar frente
frente al parlamento de Alemania que por
cierto iban todos muy a Doc a la ocasión
como dicta la etiqueta británica no se
les ve normalmente así de bien vestido
según me contaba mi colega Bueno este
tema del glamuro de la realeza británica
que constantemente es trivializado
tampoco es una casualidad no esto es un
trabajo si se puede decir de mercadeo
que han hecho durante décadas los
miembros de la familia real y eso es en
parte lo que los hace tan famosos ante
el mundo y le pongo un par de ejemplos
que seguro usted conoce mejor que yo la
transmisión del matrimonio de la Reina
Isabel segunda por televisión que en su
momento fue un gran Boom y un grandísimo
paso progresista de la monarquía que
antes era completamente cerrada a la
población y después la presencia de una
figura como Lady di que definitivamente
popularizó a otro nivel la monarquía
británica ahora lo que nos preguntamos
es si un rey tan longevo Carlos tercero
va a ser capaz de dar un salto que se
adapte a las necesidades de la
actualidad porque aquí lo que muchas
personas se preguntan es si la monarquía
va a sobrevivir de aquí en adelante
después de siete décadas de Isabel II
sin duda el glamour como como lo
mencionas es fundamental ahora la pompa
y circunstancia es inherente a esta
monarquía particularmente Y si hablamos
de monarquías menos populares uno de los
motivos es cabalmente porque no tienen
esa ese como se le llama en Reino Unido
pero el Tree pero el el
o digamos esta cualidad si se le quiere
llamar así de del de los británicos de
ser tan
pues tan serios tan Regios tan
protocolarios pues eso es parte de la
identidad de la nación por eso funciona
la monarquía y si lo vemos desde la
perspectiva histórica pues es un país de
sobrevivientes sobrevivieron la invasión
romana pero la de los sajones pero la de
los normandos pero la pero se la pasaron
en guerra con Francia ocho siglos es
decir la monarquía es parte de esto no
nada más es un país que que ha sido que
fue imperialista o colonialista sino que
también ellos mismos han vivido
Pues esta supervivencia por querer ser
siempre Atrapado no se habla de quien se
hablaba entonces en el mucho antes del
medievo antiguo que quien tenía Britania
tenía las Islas o sea tenía el
continente por Pues por esta cercanía
pero a la vez una lejanía que hacía que
fueran una fortaleza entonces creo que
esa es la influencia es su supervivencia
es su identidad es su cultura es la
personalidad Y eso es lo que dice desde
luego la Constitución monárquica que El
Monarca debe de representar si viene
esta esta imagen de la monarquía es lo
que hacia el exterior se proyecta pues
hay que hablar acerca del tema político
no que es muy importante si bien un
monarca nunca entrega opiniones
oficiales sobre los temas políticos sí
los influencia y es considerado una
figura de respeto para los
parlamentarios británicos ahora lo que
nos preguntamos es si esta figura de
respeto en lo político y en las materias
internacionales va a seguir viéndose
igual de representada con Carlos tercero
y aquí ya es mi última pregunta
ahora sí trataré de ser breve bueno
Carlos tercero fue un príncipe de gales
que opinaba mucho pero no lo hacía en
público lo hacía en lo privado y al
final El Monarca no debe de hablar en
público pero sí debe de y esto lo dice
también la Constitución
advertir y debe
culminar o sea él también puede hacerlo
seguro lo hará Pero al final de cuentas
y quiero nada más cerrar con con tu
pregunta anterior y esta y la voy a
condensar muy fácilmente
qué Cuáles son las necesidades actuales
Cuál es la modernidad pues bueno en el
Reino Unido no quieren que sus impuestos
se vayan simplemente a
a una coronación simple o a un monarca
que solamente corta listones y saluda a
gente ellos pagan impuestos para ver
esto que estamos viendo aquí el bentley
de estado la ceremonia la pompa y un
monarca que es influyente un monarca que
tiene la capacidad de poder hablar de tú
a tú con el Primer Ministro y Warren
advertirle y decirle puedo comentar
alrededor de esto O sea me parece que él
tiene la personalidad que no tenía hace
40 años no es el mismo imberbe que era
cuando se casó con Lady di Por supuesto
que no una monarquía que debe
representar internacionalmente de la
diplomacia del Reino Unido Y que además
tendrá que lidiar entre otras cosas con
todos los temas de polémicas de su hijo
que acaba de publicar un libro que está
todavía en litigios legales y que ha
contado algo muy importante de la
monarquía y son esos momentos privados
que tan celosamente ha guardado durante
décadas Yo le agradezco mucho a usted de
Gabriela Morales casas periodista
especializada en realeza y sociedad
directora de El principado por estar con
nosotros y por sus apreciaciones que
tenga buen día Muchas gracias Un saludo
en Bogotá a todos y a nuestros
televidentes quédense con nosotros ya
regresamos con más de directo a América
[Música]